the electricity surging to your
appliances
tv and lights
doesn't have the smoothest ride from its
power source
some of the energy traveling through
transmission lines typically made of
aluminum or copper
is lost when electrons crash into atoms
these losses wouldn't happen if the
wires were made of superconductors
materials that conduct electricity
without any resistance
the applications span beyond wires to
powerful magnets that can be used to
levitate trains
and extremely energy efficient computer
chips
there are many types of superconductors
most require frigid temperatures to
operate which limits how easily they can
be utilized but in october of 2020 after
decades of searching researchers
reported a superconductor that worked at
about 15 degrees celsius the temperature
of a well-maintained wine cellar
this breakthrough came with a different
caveat the superconductor required
intense pressure to function
almost three-quarters of the pressure at
the earth's center the first
superconductors discovered in 1911 were
elemental metals such as mercury cooled
to just above absolute zero
at that temperature electrons no longer
bump into atoms when they're traveling
the room temperature superconductor was
created by crushing carbon sulfur and
hydrogen between two diamond jaws that
eventually exploded
this resulted in a carbonaceous sulfur
hydride one of a class of materials that
combine hydrogen with other elements
other hydrides that superconduct at high
temperatures include a lanthanum hydride
material as well as an itrium hydride
while some researchers are eagerly
pursuing hydrides that work at ambient
pressures
others say the field is moving too fast
skeptics raise several concerns among
them that hydrides haven't demonstrated
a key component of superconductivity
the ability to push away magnetic fields
also known as the meissner effect
the high pressure of hydrides make it
difficult to measure the meissner effect
instead researchers have tested magnetic
susceptibility how magnetic an object
becomes when exposed to a magnetic field
other superconductors become less
magnetized as temperature decreases but
carbonaceous sulfur hydride doesn't
follow this trend
it initially becomes less magnetized
below the critical temperature where the
material begins to superconduct
after further cooling the reverse
happened
critics say this suggests that either
hydrides are not superconductors
or that they operate differently than
other groups of superconductors
if the hydrides are superconductors
scientists think two strategies can make
them work at lower pressures
chemical combinations with spare
electrons to move through the material
and stabilizing the structure so it
doesn't need external pressure to stay
locked in place so far they have
discovered two promising classes of
hydrides with different 3d structures
one is a cage of hydrogen atoms
surrounding a heavy metal atom which
supplies lots of electrons
the other creates a stronger
interlocking grid by combining hydrogen
and other light elements such as sulfur
while researchers are still working to
replicate the 2020 finding the group
behind the csh discovery has already
teased results of a hydride that could
function at way lower pressures
even lower pressures and diamonds won't
have to be sacrificed to create hydride
superconductors in the future